Luke and Tom here at the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel and we just bought an
abandoned Homestead in the interior of
Alaska over the next few days we're
going to be hiking to our property and
discovering what we've gotten ourselves
into we're not 100 sure what's gonna
happen but we know it's going to be
awesome
[Music]
yeah Tom this looks kind of deep why
don't you go first what
not like slipping oh take it out these
are blueberry bushes a lot of blueberry
bushes here
all right there's the marker that's one
of the corners of our property yeah we
just entered our property
cloudberry right there
oh my goodness oh geez
so good Dad I found a broken knife
oh my goodness oh wow
what have I gotten myself into what'd
you find Tom thought of a
and machetes
jack stands size another Shetty there's
a lot of machetes
there's a bit
oh check this out Tom that's a cooking
spit
yeah it's gonna need some cleaning
some tools
why is there a stop sign here oh I took
it out they got solar panels these
actually look like they're in pretty
decent shape
this is like a desk or something
oh we got Lumber under here there's bags
of Quikrete a lot of building supplies
under there some chain link a whole
bunch of this mesh that's a bike rack to
a car whole bunch of piping
is that unlocked yeah okay open it up
let's see what's inside
what do you guys oh we got electricity
oh we got a battery bank I think this is
the inverter system to the solar panels
Tom
oh
nine and a half thousand watt dual fuel
generator that is not bad now look
there's a 240 volt outlet and that goes
that goes into there and then that line
goes down there I think that generator
is hooked up to that cabin
all right
[Music]
yeah oh that fired up very nicely that
right there is a good find buddy yeah
it's an old boom box for cassette tapes
you ever seen one of those before Tom no
splitting malls shovels rakes more
shovels yeah that's a weed whacker all
right
got some duct tape crowbar these are
splitting walls
the tractor hydraulic fuel
what on Earth is that I don't even want
to know what that that's that's fuzzy
we're gonna put that over there whole
bunch of hand sanitizer
I do not know what that is that is that
nutsert nails and fasteners oil
healthy collection of mason jars
I only got some more room up here I
think this plywood is just resting on
this
all righty should go check out this
other cabin
uh microwave and a bunch of food items
oh this is a this is a composting toilet
I've got 30 gallon water jug
this is the non-demand propane water
heater right there
what is this
multi-chlor sodium hypochlorite
I think this is a water treatment
chemical for like killing bacteria in
your drinking water that is a lot of it
holy mackerel this is an oil lamp
yeah this is this is an oil lamp look at
that yeah that's a water pump right
there there's a water pressure tank holy
mackerel yeah looks like somebody tried
to make a shower yeah that is a shower
drain check this out here's the cabin
small
small this is this works
yeah I'm not going on the top bunk this
is bigger than our TV at home oh dude
there's a fridge here
that's a nice stove that'll keep us warm
in the winter time we got some pots look
at this little wood stove in there hot
water tank on the side for making hot
water they've got an air fryer oh
gotta have your air fryer man
here's the drain to the kitchen just a
five gallon bucket ah the water's
actually hooked up to something I think
the water is actually hooked up to that
Reservoir right there we can fill up
that 30 gallon drum I think we can
actually get water in here
oh that's that's really gross
apparently got some dishes to do you
want to go take upstairs
carpet and bed
there's a pulley system for taking stuff
up and down
yeah oh that's pretty cool huh
foreign
big propane tank I think that one's got
propane in it
got some cross-country skis here
I don't know what
a lot of concrete mixing wood underneath
the cabin
looks like a hunting deer stand right
here
empty empty empty so playset
I think these are truck tire chains
oh these are more tire chains
nope Halo hey Tom check this out
oh that's a log splitter that's a nice
one too
oh that'll come in handy
a little playset in there
another jug it's a light it's a
construction light some Christmas lights
hello
oh those are falling wedges
tools vitamins fish eggs there is some
random stuff here isn't there
there's a little bit of gas in there see
oh
I wouldn't mind having a snow machine
I'll have to get that thing running
uh
yeah I don't I don't think this one's
running
oh there's the outhouse
there's the toilet paper there's the
seat
put it down you can sit on it not the
worst Outhouse I've ever seen all the
Poo goes in that steel barrel and when
it gets full you throw some diesel fuel
in there and burn it up looks like the
previous owners were working on building
another cabin
broken floor jack
some old stove pipe another composting
toilet Tommy you know what we can do
with this WWE on Earth is Ray thinking
about now
oh
I think this plywood's gonna be rotten
pretty soon I think that's the tarp That
was supposed to be covering it
what is this
that goes to a fly fishing raft
that is the seat see that's where the
orlocks are that is so Random
they got a little Quonset hut over here
we gotta go check that out what do you
see Tom check this out
look at this Tom
okay any Keys yeah yeah oh oh you got
juice turn the key to the right
oh my goodness come on scoot over buddy
you want to take this for a spin yes all
right let's try it
this just died on us let's uh
well that's not good
[Music]
I think we just broke down let's start
with the basics
there's definitely gas Let's uh
starter fluid
that's for the winch
those look like brake pads to me
okay this is coolant Let's see we got
plenty of coolant
okay
let's see air filter down there and this
is disconnected that looks like that
goes in there you put your finger right
there and hold that
oh Tommy
it's running
I think we figured it out test it let
your speaker go
that's an air pressure
high five
I am wet and sloppy Tommy let's get our
backpacks inside let's do some lunch I'm
hungry
oh
there we go oh oh we got light
who
yeah he is up
I see a light up there what how does
that turn on see the wire goes there
the sensor on this side
the generator died that turns the
generator on and off look there's a
little remote that turns on and off the
generator oh that's great then you don't
have to go out to the generator room to
turn it on and off oh okay what's this
what's this
oh we got light
yeah that's light I'll tell you what
it's a little bit chilly in here so I
think we need to get a fire started
foreign
[Music]
wood
your kind of meal yes
ah look out for some dessert should we
Chips Ahoy and hot chocolate
yeah that was a good hard day so I'm
stealing him
look
[Music]
up
do you want your sleeping bag and pillow
yeah
yeah the police
yeah I'm coming up look at this there's
three mattresses here there's one for
each one of you boys
Tommy's backpack got soaked through and
so his clothes are a little damp we're
gonna hang him up and dry him
you didn't watch some shows on my phone
yeah all right let's let's do that
oh you want some popcorn we can do
popcorn
[Music]
thank you
have a good day bud
yep
you're gonna be warm enough
all right guys I'm gonna put the camera
down I'm gonna go to bed I'm gonna see
you guys in the morning we got a lot of
work tomorrow
it seems like it's raining a little less
hard today
all right
what's up
no sit on your seat please there's your
hot chocolate
try using your fork if it's just
just has a straw as soon as I get done
with these dishes we're going outside
[Music]
I think it's time for us to get to work
all right I think number one on my
agenda is cleaning up we've got so much
stuff just laying out here in the
weather if it's garbage we gotta get rid
of it if it's worth keeping we got to
put it away in the shed we got a lot to
do yeah
[Music]
stop
[Applause]
[Music]
where are you take it up let's take it
over to the burn barrel
foreign
you like it up there yes
[Applause]
[Music]
I keep finding these random piles of
cordwood scattered across the property
so I'm trying to consolidate them all
underneath that little shed over there
so when the snow falls we can find our
firewood and get at it easily
[Music]
wood that would free me up
time you hungry yeah should we get lunch
I'll hold it up okay yeah okay we're
gonna get a first aid kit okay no we're
in a hole still you know how you can
tell whether you need stitches
if you can see the fat when you look
down in the cut
Thomas I think you need stitches buddy
no yeah it's gonna take us a while to
get out of here so we need to kind of
just leave everything and get out of
here if we're gonna get your stitches
you think I'm overreacting
thank you
took some driving but we found ourselves
a town with a clinic
you did good bud you did good
handiwork oh yeah you got a fuzzy finger
now you are so brave too Vietnam is it
starting to feel better though yeah it
feels better it does not hurt at all
nurses were so nice yeah the nurses were
awesome
eat
here Tom sit down eat some food okay
I spent about half my day getting to and
from the clinic so I got a lot of work
left to do yet
there we go got the wood taken care of
check it out this is all tongue and
groove siding this goes together
like that but it's just scrap pieces I
don't know if it's enough to do the
inside of the cabin or anything but some
of it's starting to get weathered and
rotten yeah
[Applause]
a big box of construction scraps some
good firewood in there
a massive pile of end pieces here
well I got a garbage can full of these
end pieces over by the wood pile but
I'll never burn through all of this holy
mackerel that's a lot gotta figure out
what I'm gonna do with all these scraps
well we've gotten a lot done so far but
man there's so much left to do I'm gonna
take a break and try to fiddle with this
snow machine a little bit I'd really
like to know whether or not we have a
working snow machine
disconnected
[Music]
gonna wipe this spark plug on my shirt
really well
[Applause]
[Music]
that that looks broken let's see if this
other Arctic Cat has a good belt in it
ah there we go that actually looks brand
spanking new
there we go
if we can swap this out
I'm like oh I got it on top no way I
didn't think that was gonna happen
well the reverse doesn't seem to be
working so we're gonna have to do this
the hard way
thank you
[Applause]
no machine
[Music]
oh those two strokes are so sticky
well that'll be useful come winter time
glad we got that running that is such a
big deal
you tired are you tired
yeah well we need to get your energy up
oh
I like that oh yeah sir
oh that was definitely not healthy but
man that was good
dessert you want some black licorice no
thank you sure you don't want the black
hooker pretty sure it's the best flavor
come on
you got do you get enough to eat yeah
you want to shoot on some fireworks yeah
yeah
oh
oh ah
run run run
run run run run that thing trying to
kill us only one ER visit per day that's
our rule
run
[Applause]
was that cool yeah I think it's bedtime
bud
well believe it or not it's about 10
o'clock and it is late so we've got to
get this boy to bed all right I'm gonna
put the camera down I will see you guys
in the morning
yeah this has been so wet this summer
turned everything into a mud hole
we got a lot to do around here but
number one on my agenda is fixing this
Trail the rain has made it into a muddy
mess and every time we drive this side
by side it just makes the ruts and mud
holes deeper previously owner put a
bunch of logs in here to keep it from
becoming too deep oh it gets deep right
here Tom
that's a good idea
but
was it there is a load of dead timber in
here I think we could build this Trail
up pretty good but I didn't bring my
chainsaw
you know we didn't even check out this
greenhouse it's a greenhouse but there's
no door middle of the summer though so I
think we're a little past the planting
season but not quite sure how they got
in there
me
all in all I paid 77 000 for five acres
of land this cabin and everything on it
Tom you think that was a good deal good
deal it was a really good deal well I've
got a lot of plans for this property and
a lot of projects in mind if you guys
want to see those videos make sure to
click subscribe to the outdoor Boys
YouTube channel we put out new videos
every Saturday morning if you like this
video don't forget to check out the
outdoor Boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that Bell button
and you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
oh